un moral de la tam géopolitologue
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france l'ethiopie affirme donc qu'elle
n'utilisera l'eau que pour produire de
l'électricité ce que son objectif
pourrait être de devenir le plus grand
exportateur d'énergie d'afrique
oui vous avez entièrement raison
les intentions de l'ethiopie est une
forme diderot l'hégémonie et en ce sens
l'ethiopie veut jouer un rôle des plus
importants dans l'avenir par rapport à
la distribution hausse et d'électricité
c'est pourquoi vous avez évoqué
effectivement l'egypte mais aussi le
soudan le soudain qui paraît comme j
mais depuis dix ans demande une gestion
mixte afin de pouvoir bénéficier de
prêts des tristes et moindre alors
l'égypte on a besoin pour faire face à
la croissance de sa population qui
dépend du fleuve pour ses besoins en eau
le barrage éthiopien va avoir une grande
incidence sur cette exploitation énorme
il ya pratiquement 100 millions de
personnes en egypte qui vont se
retrouver pratiquement privés d'eau
c'est pourquoi il est question du
remplissage en aval de ce barrage mais
je tiens à vous le dire vous êtes face à
une prochaine guerre de l'eau qui va se
dérouler sous nos yeux
vous avez en réduction en afrique ce qui
se passe entre le tibet la chine
les égyptiens n'admettront jamais que
ceux qui tiennent le robinet soit les
éthiopiens et vous allez voir très
rapidement et prochainement qui a déjà
des des diplomates égyptiens qui sont
sortis de leur droit de réserve et on
dit que bombarderait littéralement ce
barrage ces négociations devaient
s'interrompre se verra ce sera un motif
aussi dit et nous avons perdu la
connexion est en train de retrouver
morad el hattab et est ce que vous vous
à retrouver visiblement oui alors
l'égypte revendiquent des droits
historiques sur le nil l'egypte qui
refuse de revenir sur les accords de
partage des eaux qui remonte à l'époque
coloniale britannique est ce que ces
accords sont encore légitime selon vous
oui l'egypte je sais pas si je voulais
entendu l'egypte risque tête à sa
population plus de 100 millions
personnes à risque d'être privé de hoard
egypte l'egypte ne se laissera pas faire
c'est comme je vous le disais la chine
et le tibet l'egypte ne permettra pas
été oublié de te dire le robinet donc
vous verrez d'ici peu une guerre de
l'eau l'egypte interviendra
militairement l'ethiopie pour faire
valoir ses droits parce que sinon tout
un pan de l'agriculture égyptienne va se
retrouver par terre
merci pour votre intervention morale
dallas table géopolitologue et pardon
pour ce petit soucis de connexion